salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
j'espère que vous avez la patate parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce sont elles qui passent
à la casserole on va parler frites qui
les a inventées les Français les Belges
j'ai la réponse
[Musique]
bienvenue dans sur la planche si ce
format vous plaît n'hésitez pas à liker
cette vidéo ou à vous abonner si ce
n'est pas déjà fait comme ça je pourrais
continuer à vous faire saliver les
frites chaque année nous en mangeons
plus de 11 millions de tonnes soit près
de 350 kg par seconde 350 700 1050 1400
bon on s'arrête là et il existe même un
pays où elles ont été élevées au rang de
trésor national vous avez deviné ici la
Belgique pour nos voisins cela ne fait
aucun doute les frites viennent de
Belgique elles auraient été inventées au
17e siècle dans la ville de Namur à 70
km au sud de Bruxelles à cette époque
les Namurois se nourrissent
essentiellement de petits poissons qu'il
pêche dans la Meuse avant de les faire
frire mais au cours d'anniversaire
particulièrement rude la Meuse gel
impossible de pêcher les Namurois ont
alors l'idée de remplacer les poissons
par des pommes de qu'il taille en
bâtonnets afin qu'il ressemble au petit
poisson des bâtonnets qu'ils font
ensuite frire voilà comment serait né
les frites en Belgique je les aime bien
moi les belges mais ils savent comment
les Américains appellent les frites les
French freeze les frites françaises cela
dit tout le monde n'est pas d'accord sur
l'origine de cette expression
on raconte qu'elle serait dû à une
erreur des soldats américains pendant la
Première Guerre mondiale alors qu'ils
sont stationnés en Belgique ils
découvrent les frites mais les Belges
qu'il est leur servent sont francophones
des Wallons que les Américains prennent
pour des Français bah oui beige français
les Américains ne font pas bien la
différence voici pourquoi ils ont
attribué à ce plat qu'ils adorent le nom
de French rise sauf que cette histoire
ne serait qu'une légende en fait
l'expression serait bien plus ancienne
on la retrouve d'ailleurs dans des
livres de recettes américains dater des
années 1850
et ce n'est pas tout le terme French ne
voudrait même pas dire français il se
trouve qu'en anglais to French est un
verbe qui n'est plus utilisé il vient de
l'Irlandais du vieil irlandais et il
veut dire
émincer French rise signifierait donc
tout simplement que les pommes de terre
ont été coupées en long morceaux ce ni
plus ni moins la définition du mot frite
c'est ça les frites sont irlandaises
maintenant il nous prend pour des
Américains du coup ça complique un peu
les choses la question n'est pas de
savoir si les frites sont belles ou
françaises mais si elles sont belges
françaises irlandaise ou américaine
[Musique]
les historiens ont tranché la frite
aurait été inventée à la toute fin du
XVIIIe siècle ou au début du 19e à Paris
et plus précisément sur les bords de la
Seine je le savais à cette époque des
vendeuses de beignets sont installés sur
le pont Neuf ce sont elles qui ont
l'idée de tremper des pommes de terre
découper en rondelles dans une friture
de saindoux les vendent dans le quartier
où sont installés plusieurs théâtres et
comme le théâtre ça creuse et bien après
la représentation les spectateurs
viennent déguster ses savoureuses pommes
de terre frites que l'on surnomme les
pommes du Pont-Neuf dans les années 1820
1830 elles deviennent très populaires on
dit même que Charles Baudelaire et
Victor Hugo en raffole Victor Hugo se
promenant sur les quais de la Seine en
mangeant des frites j'aurais bien aimé
voir ça mais les rondelles posent des
problèmes au moment de la cuisson elle
se colle les unes aux autres du coup on
décide de les couper en bâtonnet ça
c'est la bonne taille et c'est comme ça
que je les aime la frite prend sa forme
définitive et au milieu du 19e siècle
elle rentre dans les livres de cuisine
bon vous voyez où je veux en venir
les frites ont donc bien été inventé en
France ça c'est dit mais ce sont les
Belges qui vont les populariser grâce à
un Allemand face un Allemand maintenant
manquait plus que ça
en 1844 Jean-Frédéric Krieger un forain
originaire de Bavière ouvre la première
baraque à frite en Belgique baptisée
Fritz elle propose des pommes de terre
frites à la parisienne quelle audace
rassurez-vous le forain a pris le métier
dans une rôtisserie de Montmartre la
friture il connaît Krieger alias le roi
de l'Afrique sillonne les foires de
Belgique où il rencontre un immense
succès grâce à lui en seulement quelques
années les frites deviennent un
classique de la cuisine belge
aujourd'hui on estime à 5000 le nombre
de frites chez nos voisins le produit
est tellement associé à la Belgique que
chaque année le 1er août on y célèbre la
Journée internationale de l'Afrique
belge de frites des frites des frites
des frites moi c'est la frite française
que je célèbre on l'a compris belge
français ont apporté chacun à leur
manière leur pierre à l'édifice mais qui
des deux détient la meilleure recette
là aussi la bataille fait rage
chez nous pour les frites on est plutôt
du genre vite fait bien fait une seule
cuisson dans de l'huile végétale alors
que nos voisins en Belgique eux
pratiquent la double cuisson on ne
s'embête pas trop non plus sur le choix
des pommes de terre on utilise de
nombreuses variétés pourvu qu'elles
soient assez farineuse grâce à la forte
quantité d'amidon qu'elle contiennent
les pommes de terre farineuses se
prêtent très bien à la friture elle
présente aussi l'avantage de ne pas trop
absorber l'huile durant la cuisson
je confirme mais vu de Belgique la
méthode française est considérée comme
un sacrilège là-bas on plaisante pas non
plus sur la matière première pour les
Belges une seule et unique pomme de
terre est digne de finir en frites la
Binche cette pomme de terre originaire
des Pays-Bas est assez farineuse juste
ce qu'il faut une fois qu'elles sont
bien nettoyées correctement épluchées il
faut les trancher mais là aussi
attention les Belges sont intransigeants
pas question de les couper sous forme
d'allumettes les frites seraient
beaucoup trop grasses plus elles sont
fines et plus elles absorbent l'huile de
cuisson une frite belge c'est un
centimètre de large pas plus mais pas
moins les puristes réalisent la découpe
au couteau comme ceci mais il n'est pas
interdit d'utiliser un coupe frites ça
tombe bien j'en ai un
[Musique]
un centimètre c'est parfait une fois
réduite en bâtonnet il faut les laisser
reposer pendant 20 minutes ensuite on
peut passer à la première cuisson comme
je vous le disais en Belgique la cuisson
a lieu en deux temps pour la pré cuisson
on trempe les frites dans de la graisse
de bœuf le chauffer à environ 160 degrés
ça leur donne du goût au bout de cinq à
six minutes de cuisson on les retire et
on les laisse reposer pas plus d'une
vingtaine de minutes ensuite on passe à
la seconde cuisson
faut pas être trop pressé pour manger
des frites en Belgique cette fois dans
de l'huile végétale à 180 degrés et
comme par miracle au bout d'une petite
minute trente nos frites sont des arbres
bien dorés il ne reste plus qu'à les
sortir les égoutter et salés la première
cuisson permet en fait de cuire la chair
de la pomme de terre la seconde permet
de frire voilà pourquoi les frites
belges sont à la fois fondantes et
croustillantes à la fois cuite à coeur
et parfaitement saisie contrairement à
une idée reçue les Belges ne sont pas
les plus gros mangeurs de frites en
Europe il n'arrive qu'en troisième
position derrière les Français et
surtout les Britanniques ils les
consomme très souvent avec du poisson
c'est le célèbre fish and chips j'adore
ça quand on record du monde du plus gros
mangeur de frites il n'est pas belge
mais
français il est originaire des hautes
France il a ingurgité 900 g de frites en
moins de 6 minutes c'est l'équivalent de
8 portions alors vu comme ça ça ne
paraît pas énorme mais je ne vous
conseille pas d'essayer depuis 2015 nous
détenons également le record du plus
gros cornet de frites 6 tonnes 2 c'est
le poids de 5 petites voitures 5
citadines et à votre avis à qui a-t-on
ravi le titre à la Belgique évidemment
si vous avez beaucoup d'argent à
dépenser sachez qu'un restaurant New
York a établi le record de la portion de
frites la plus chère au monde elle est
vendue 200 dollars elles sont cuisinées
avec du champagne de la truffe et la
sauce qui les accompagne contient un peu
d'or en poudre personnellement je me
contenterai les miennes
je récapitule ce sont donc les Français
qui ont inventé la frite à Paris mais
c'est bien la frite belge qui fait
figure de référence gastronomique on
peut donc siffler la fin de cette vidéo
sur la planche sur un match nul merci
beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout c'est le meilleur soutien
que vous pouvez apporter à la chaîne je
vous dis à très bientôt j'ai encore
plein d'histoires gourmandes à vous
raconter
[Applaudissements]